so our next speaker is Ling Ling
Sciences and she represents the latest
generation of people that actually
served on her thesis defense committee
which is at the University of
Connecticut and they remain friends
since then her laboratory studies RNAs
and and the goal is to identify new RNAs
and she's identified a number of very
interesting non-coding rnas and
clergymen including circle RNAs that
have been implicated in human disease
gene regulation and function
I did my PhD with Gordon Carmichael at
UConn Health Center and in the early of
2009 I invited a city to be my other
campus cities reviewer I still remember
that they see the drove the car all the
way to Farmington and stayed for over
than two hours with the rest of other
committee members and me in a small
conference room I cannot recall how many
questions I was asked by the fennel
outcome was present and they let me pass
so thank you but today I feel I had a
feeling like kind of probably defense
again in front of so many masters in the
room anyway so I also thank my friend
Donna and okay
this one it is about this about biter
okay sorry about that yeah anyway so and
then in the summer of 2009 I Jones out
of my library Union and this is a
picture here's Sid and this is me and I
believe this is Professor McLean it's my
luck to become a member of Professor see
the Ottomans research group this large
because of this guy yeah the post always
seed from 2004 to 2006
and he is my husband and also now we
have collaboration on computational
biology alright so today I'm going to
talk about about Genesis and also a
little bit of functional application of
several uh non-korean species we've been
working with so a well gonna set up my
lab in Shanghai I really want to study
with some new are raised to work with
the rather than looking at the whole
identity
aren't just Krypton which are known to
contain most of MRIs and the link horns
transcript from intergenic region there
is very simple hypothesis that they are
probably some annealing RNA they don't
have poly tails but yet would be
identified so we decided to look at a
non poly on a transcript on the method
is very straightforward so we collect
the total are raised treacherous things
want to remove any possible gene
contamination and we did this in human
ear cells at gentleman and the hilar
cells but the key thing is we have to be
very careful so we do multiple runs of
all of the key selection and we collect
not only the poly are but also the
polyamory so for the non-color our part
we then treat multiple on the ribosome
iron depletion and then which is a
self-selection to collect our innate
longer than 200 nucleotides for our
sequencing Oliver I've shown you
examples of we have very clean
fractionation of the poly are raised and
non poly always a way from some stable
nonpolar a our signals derive from both
intelligence and action regions and
these are signals tend to be two types
of circular arrays and also Sonoran
ended the land encoding our eyes so the
first type of a circle are on the way
fun is called circular in training
arrays they were from Incheon Larry's so
if the in Chun contains the Jewish
motive close to the fur from specified
and the yudish mode of close to the
brand Poinsett now such in Chandler it
is resistant to the branching and
forming a class of new re Co CRA shown
you one example here this is the gene
coding and 52 its second in chalk and
produce a circular array so under the
initial jar we can tell that the
circular R Omega is much more slowly
than is linear isoform
and when we treated the samples with
ours are which is in them can cut or
that just as linear army and West Roger
arabela can preserve a circular army now
we found this cheese's sample and
untreated samples they still matrix to
the same position so suggesting
although they derived from the initial
areas but it does not mean they do not
contain the supreme lenient hill and we
found some of such circles can promote
our promise to transcription uses with
unknown mechanism okay so the second
group of the Clarins are more broadly
detectable in medicines and these are is
a produce from expressing
of exons so this occurrence was
originally identified in over 25 years
ago but only identified in handful of
cases with application of the nampalli
our sequencing now thousands of cyclists
can be identified in meta zones from
fruit fly to Mars and to human several
studies revealed that Tsukasa can
regulate gene expression by targeting
microRNAs affecting transcription and
also interfering with splicing so back
splicing like it's the downstream 5
prime splice in cell to the upstream
through promise of blessing said so the
question is how this blossom can
overcome this sterically and further
action we and others have found that the
complementary sequences most of them are
elements in human beings in the Frankie
introns of the circle are forming
Addison's
they can form the dobson aren't pairing
therefore they can bring the splicing
says close together to facilitate a peg
splicing however the presence of such
sequences are important but they are not
sufficient and because our information
is regulated by the competition of the
personal information of course or within
the intron for example if the double
strand are forming within the individual
in turn it will promote the canonical
splicing but if our pairing occurs
across the intron it can promote axon
secularization for example hershey's you
if these two exons can form so clearly
and they are flagging by other elements
can form of the appearing you can see
the Sakura formation can be detected
here if we change the load to the non
repetitive outcome
complementary sequences again they can
strongly endorses the current formation
because now they become the fully
complementary however if we introduce
another competition pair within this in
Chong now it can
computer blocks account information so
it's very interesting thing and also we
found over 50% of the X PRIZE the gene
can produce circle on race and then can
produce multiple siclari's from one
single gene lockers
here's just one example from the DMSO
transfers therapy we can detect multiple
circular R is produced from this region
and some of the abundant ones can be
verified by northern blotting so we
think the whether they should auto
elements and their competition can lead
to a Tundra localization in humans as
well as Mouse indeed such competition
tell it to the fact splicing set
selection either the fat from splash and
fair selection proximal or distal
depends where the doctor are formation
occurs or the super supreme self
selection if the Sicari containing
multiple axons an inhibition to the
alternative of expressing cell selection
we found our four basic types of
foreigners cannot express site selection
also occurs within the sakaki's
including the exons introns asian turn
field specify selection so firmly secure
are a biogenesis is complex so now the
question is how bad surprising is linked
to transcription whether it occurs coat
encryption lay our post
transcriptionally to tackle this
question which studies the current
processing using the Fazio tagging of
the national honours followed by our
sequencing which also qualifies you dr
music so first year first to GRDC has
been used to study our promise to
elongation so basically with the cells
with dr p which is
inhabit her can be universally blocked
photo transcription for three hours and
then we wash out that there are be took
in your part with transcription at the
same time and for CEO which is analog of
the uridine to label the RNA for
different time periods and then we
collect this nation on earth with deeply
divisive liberal Robson army to increase
informative mapping and then we did our
sequencing with or without army without
as our treatment so we have generally
this set of data in p1 cells which is a
human and chronic Cosmo Rosalind as
nan-zhao and assonance out the fridge
for neurons so here you see how we
realize the back supplies as well as
events for particular de locas so here's
the gene copy NPR to its second and
third acts on the conform circularly so
basically called the splicing Junction
is and the backsplash injunction race
and the number of them represent the
Redwood freshen of circular and less
linearly and at the steady state you can
tell that the attraction of this
folklore is comparable to the linear
Celeste re however in the national state
the expression of the supply is much
more slow lower compared to the
canonical splicing yeah
as these lockers so this to say the
processing of so currently at Nessun
level by this process um is very low and
it is also true on the global scale so
here we connect the total BS g rate and
also the total upstream and downstream
backspin junctions of the exact same
actions so about less than percent of
the axon can go back splicing so blossom
doesn't really like to do back splicing
an in digital fancy current processing
logic occurs post transcriptionally
she's here the transition of most genes
had terminated after 16 minutes of the
transcription and we found the splicing
junction sides of the kinetics glycine
risk to a platform about two hours
however the splicing Junction said for
the pack splicing keep accumulating such
a scene is larger occurs posted
transitionally the interesting thing is
although they occur suppose
traditionally our fund sook are
producing genes tend to transcribe
quickly we found for the necessarily
using genes that transcription
elongation rate is about 2.9 KB per
minute however on average for the nasa
karan genes is about 3 kV per minute and
we further very verified this
observation by multi loading modulating
portal elongation racing cells so in
brief we free slowdown pol II
transcription we can see lower level of
finessing saccharin could be produced
and if we increase the pol ii
transcription we see most current would
be produced so why this happen
well viral check your hypothesis is this
fast portal elongation theorist
non-canonical arm pairing of those
complementary sequences the cross axons
therefore facility back splicing and we
also found Sakaki has very long
half-life some of the surgeries at the
stead state is many due to their
accumulation and this is a particular
tool in South a very slow division rate
for example in neurons so it will be
fresh in human ear cells to foreigner on
we find both the number and the
expression level of Sakura's
are significantly increased at a steady
state it also attend and the one we did
was that's not our sequencing we found
such genes tend to be transcribed
quickly in neurons and when we compare
the Nessen level of the second
expression we found at the national
level some Sakaki
produce a faster or slower know compared
to thousands but as a tested level
most also carry a hot expressing neurons
so this is again suggest so currents
that are abundant at the zest level in
neurons transcribe quickly and
accumulate so here's the summary of the
cycle RS so by an Impala are sequencing
we found the second producer firm in
Solaris also identified the su currents
produced from maximizing of axons so for
those effects processor core is we found
there biogenesis depends on the flanking
complementary sequences and the
competition of our parenting is through
attention secularization and su current
production is very slow endogenously and
largely a cursive post transcriptionally
we also found that as a car that are
abundant at the state level tend to be
transcribed quickly and accumulate and
of course there are many questions
remain to be answered so for example
what are binding proteins associated
with their biogenesis and how are they
ultimately degradated how are they
structured and what proteins they are
associated for any potential functions
so my lab now focusing on some of those
topics to further a circular arise
now I'm going to switch my target to the
snow are age-related lung and Koreans
they're going to talk about the snow our
Angela non-korean and sparse so the non
polar are sequencing has also allowed us
to identify the snow era ended in County
Road London quarry I called snow link
our eyes so there are two types of snow
are a epoxy d and a box HEC a which are
defined by their unique structure motive
and those neurons they can act as
categories that are complementary to
attack the sequences to direct either
rebels methylation of civilization a lot
of them happen rubber some our eyes as
we know that introns are you ready grid
of splicing
but if one in turn contains to snow our
ratings now during splicing the underlay
of the snow arm she complex
and can protect the internal enchanting
RNA sequences from degradation leading
to the formation of the snow our mg
capsule an encoding eyes and we found
four different types of snow linker in
the cell either the snow link are in the
bible's CD snarly OHA CSIR once at a
city another is HACC
so we found about 20 such snowing
Harrison cells but the west striking
observation is the genomic region
including the most abundant smelling
cars in human embryonic stem cells is a
social way Stradivari syndrome so Peter
S is a genetical neuron mental well
gyrus is a neurodevelopmental genetic
disorder that has been added to the
chrome song crumbs the paternal
chromosome of 15k 11 kills 13 and this
region is the genomic imprinting lockers
so up to about 70% other of the patellas
patients they can tell the several
megabytes deletion including this
nephron and is downstream non-coding
region there are four reported cases of
the prodigy single individuals and they
contain those overlap in micro deletions
that map to unchaste this region of the
sub n G so therefore the depletion of
this non-coding region of the snap earth
has been solved as the primary cause of
the disease so previously this region
has annotated with 29 carbon epoxy DS
not only however those as no armies they
are orphans nobody knows what they are
doing in cells so how these neurons
involved in disease is unknown and we
found five viral body and snarling horns
just arrived from these lockers in
female cells and their expression is
very very high in such smelling horns
they can from nuclear accumulation close
with a set of transcription
the the interact with splicing factor
- and so we think the mazing attraction
of this nulling Harley may contribute to
the development of the disease well the
scene say since stolen cars are so
striking at their additional snow are
very little done on quarantine cells
will then perform the rebel Aryan army
in the precipitation followed by armored
sequencing so February is one of the
four K protein components of the snow
army complex and here's just our
February secret data so all the five
snow Ling highs from the PWS region can
be successfully and specifically for
down and then we look at the data we
found about 20 snow are a little on on
chorus and among these snow are little
in cars we found yet another new
toppling highs we call spar which is
fire promise know our ended suprem
polyadenylated
and this picture she was houses bar from
the protagoras cinema region look like
in the nucleus so the stretchy scene is
the genomic region including two spars
in stem cells again is of social with a
sheet of ice so the first is power costs
per one it just located to the
downstream of us enough energy all right
an upstream of snow link army and if we
look at the fabula IP
peak can see that the peak region
corresponds very precisely to the box it
is not already called snow 107 and its
downstream positively to our sequencing
and were able to verify the spa
existence in stem cells and spa one
contains seven axons and the spliced s
inform is about 35,000 nucleotides
it's really long non-coding RNA so as we
know that most helpful known port will
transcribe the matter
Aksum containing arrays are kept by a
meso
seven quadrant group at the ferryman and
so what the Magnum is involved in the
formation or the ferment of a spar the
first of all we look at our national
articles data and to look at the house
the nests not spot-on and look like our
fans bar is transcribed in fact from the
exact same promoter of the snob and
let's who say spell one is processed
from the polycistronic transcript of
this region and they wanted to recover
this malformation in the first lecture
to study their processing so here we're
loading the last two excellent of snob
and the internal sequence and also the
first box additional RNA followed by
several base pair of sparked one and the
poly a tail and then with trans factor
this plasma into hella cells which do
not make the internal spar we found that
this politician in pre army can indeed
the process into upstream MRA and
downstream spar one now when we deleted
the epoxy D it's not only all the key
motifs of it it completely eliminates
power information well has no effect on
our processing if we replace this
Antonius pawan with others not only in
the Box CD or HTC the steel forms spot
one
so suggest that this snow RNA is
important and it's required force
malformation so now in order to make the
spar it requires the continued support
for transcription after bypass the first
poly signal then we wanted to examine
whether the strength of the poly a would
have any effect on a downstream valve
our information so we delete the either
the 16 test recognition signal all
together with its
axillary sequences so the bottom line is
the Waker of the poly a signal the less
processed option I marks would be
detected I mean while we correspondingly
we can see
the accumulation of Priya and also the
increased expression of smart one but if
we delete all the policy including this
cryptic ones the process of up street of
the optimum I'm re almost the complete
block and the spell formation also
largely diminished so let's to see this
poly is important for spawn processing
passion of being a very strong one for
example if we replace this in dali poly
with a strong poly a signal from Panna
globin gene now we can see absolute mr
is stone process
however if our information is sharply
dropped so it requires a strong so I
would say it's drops from poly our
signal Ella means the spire information
okay so you ought to make the spell one
we want to test whether those factors
involved in pollination and termination
also involved is more information with
Tessa's because it's known that arm
promise for termination is functionally
connected with cleavage and the poly
relation in the Superman processing of
RA
so the key factors to examine here in
CPS factors and acts aren't too so when
knockdown CPS factors followed by the
arch PCR to see the accumulation of
priest by one so we can tell that this
priest bar is a community and we knock
down X r2 we see the similar thing this
accumulation of principal one and here
is a community of spare one by our in
protection I see so we think the forum
and the processing of spell one requires
an in-text no RNA which can be vaak
siddhi or h ACA at the fireman and also
a week extreme poly signal in in
addition the factors involving cleavage
and population and a particle
termination also involved in spire
formation i would like to mention that
spell processing is a social ways of
rapid apart will engage
wait so again we take advantage of our
national articles that have done in pure
and agile and cells we found the trust
elongation rid of these lockers is about
support for KB per minute versus
averages but 5 kb per minute in the cell
so I think this verifies the part of
elongation on the one hand can shorten
the window of the opportunity for the
upstream Superman formation to occur and
on the other hand it kind of wins the
competition which the acts aren't true
so here is the probability of collision
region this is an chancellery region of
the protein coding gene so professor
it's a UTI of snap and but now we know
this another case we have identified
many learn accordion from this region
for the spell one processing we think
it's a caucus with the rapid pulse of
transcription and a weak upstream poly
signal which allows the income
determination of potful which enables
the transcription of the downstream snow
are a gene which is located support for
KP away when the cleavage happens acts
aren't true become associate with the
cleaver non-capital national ra and acts
are to
Cleaves the RA and cheesy spot who wants
to destabilize it however part who runs
fast and rich there's no RA first and
then excellent who meets the code
functionally indominus honorably complex
two blocks a further example trimming so
this is how the fairness Pawan is formed
Adam Pottle continues its transcription
to synthesize wealth to initial run of
arm polymers to termination passio is
incomplete
alright because there's another about
who can be formed downstream of this so
this part who now aleca formulas link
array is intron content
the five snow link arms so this is a
very complicated region here's the
summary okay so this is the region
deleted in the probably syndrome
we found a spare one and esparto right
here and the spot wings on regions also
include 39 copies of snow army and also
five stolen cars this link is spa one of
our long from no 16,000 or such as five
thousand nucleotides long and smelling
horns from one kb 2 3 kappa this is a
seven Newland and Cody on the wolf on
so now was the doing cells so in fun for
the spar if we do our ID in double fish
we found by using the 1k be longshots
power and Provence power larger
localized to the paternal chromosome
which has crept which is transcriber set
but if we use the tiling innocence probe
that can match to the entire spa one
spot to and stolen cars we found this
always can accumulate very striking
accumulations they can form this like
nuclear psycho with damage her about 1
to 2 micrometer in Lance and we found
some howling highs are localized in the
middle of the cycle surrounded by the
non-overlapping sparse and as expected
this accumulation also present in IP
yourself derive from normal population
but not in the F yourself derive from
the progress patients we found this LAN
encoding on the Association multiple
armed planning proteins including
student here at sham p.m. tdp-43 Fox
fuel which are known to have a role in
neuron degeneration and also involved in
multiple aspects of our metabolism so to
further come from their association with
didn't I clip I say of each individual
are Manning protein shows you
fertility forestry for our actively in
human years us we found here before
three bands journey to this region and
this region in fact contain over 350
purity of GDP for appearances with Geo
or ug cluster and then we generated
Nakajima asylum by using CRISPR Krishna
either in the maternal cat all of this
original / Tanaka automaker the patient
situation as expected
maternal has no effect on expression of
this longing Korean is with you fund the
TV for sleep and struggling to this
region but when this armies are absent
no planning could be detected further
suggesting these arise and proteins that
were specifically interact each other an
important Aloha fund that human ear
cells lacking the snarling harness parts
have altered jeebies work for is open
inside
for example this gene called a curing
which is important for I'm getting there
for the neuromuscular Junction
information and can tell that I spun
into one of this in Chong is significant
videos after a depletion of this RI and
in fact we found out patents s of T DB e
in the absence of these RS allocated two
genes associated Iran functions and
similarly that also observed for a charm
p.m. and Fox to so here's a summary
about several personnel club as a
patient they have the position of the
paternal chromosome and 25-person have
Union Parenthood destroy me and supposed
to have the and putting the effects all
that no expression at all of these RS so
we think the Mason of these RS can have
some roles in the development of the
probability syndrome we all have this
link or in the beginning of our lives
with from speckle touch the widow's are
many proteins however if in the patient
where all they are is accompanied the
gong we have seen the miss local did not
miss localization of these are tiny
proteins all right so the take-home
message is we think Longhorns Albert
versified including including the mr
look like link Harley's transcript from
intergenic region and also a number of
from now holiday eyes we talk about snow
Lincoln siclari's and also the sparely
so with this I'd like to thank people in
my life who of these are s young it's a
very enigmatic spirits student so she
basically did all of the secular Network
chimp I worked on snow lingering horn on
spar and we have one student just join
the live in ruin did those beautiful
imaging and all the computation analysis
was in collaboration with Lee's lab at
the PSC be funny looking from I was my
Institute and also SFC the Ministry of
Technology and the sensing technology of
China and change the coming up sense
okay I'm running off the time sorry for
that thank you for attention I have a
question about the circular rnase and
you mentioned that they're abundant in
neurons have you looked at their
localization and possible transport
compartments outside the soma because
there's a very interesting whole story
about messenger RNA transport by a zip
code and zip code binding proteins of
message for local translation and
curious if you've looked into that our
selves but a group from Germany they did
the study as you suggested so the
basically look has a localization of
siclari's in the neurons and they found
many of them actually accumulate in the
new writes so but what do they do there
I still unknown is it definite possible
they can participate in the
transportation and other function as
well
it's definite for hours bar per se we
have done like black sapote restitution
and the tip lead or the pre RA but we
still see the accumulation of those
nucleus Michael's not really teen is as
neural specific spliceosomal protein so
that begs the question of whether
there's some kind of feedback or auto
regulation going on yes there is
everyone existing snap and knockout
animal
however enough hard of sniffing cannot
basically recapitulate the probability
syndrome cannot go fetch her so
therefore people you know feel that hope
you think about that deletion of its
non-coding rather than a coding region
is more important for the chillip s you
know if if you look at tdp-43 mutations
whether they affect the profile of your
didn't look at yeah but I know what
you're talking about so because there
are lots of truncation or TV for three
in a you know in a certain location but
so far only look at the white have Tilly
first rate band inviting in the cell
with or without the silicon thank you
you